vera bonjour alors que retenir de cet
échange entre les deux présidents
bonjour amira une nouvelle conversation
téléphonique entre emmanuel macron et
vladimir poutine après leur entrevue au
kremlin le 7 février dernier les deux
chefs d'état se sont mis d'accord pour
organiser une réunion du groupe de
travail afin de parvenir à un cessez le
feu dans le donbass selon le communiqué
du kremlin le président russe a exprimé
une vive préoccupation au sujet de la
grave détérioration le long de la ligne
de contact dans le donbass pour vladimir
poutine cette escalade est due aux
provocations des forces de l'ordre
ukrainiennes le président russe a
également attiré l'attention de son
homologue français sur les livraisons
d'armements et de munitions moderne à
l'ukraine effectué par les pays de
l'otan écoutez
il est à nouveau souligné que kiev ne
fait que simuler le processus de
négociation et refuse obstinément la
mise en oeuvre des accords de minsk et
des accords conclus dans le cadre du
format normandie compte tenu de
l'urgence de la situation les présidents
reconnu qu'il était opportun
d'intensifier la recherche de solution
par des moyens diplomatiques au niveau
des ministères des affaires étrangères
et des conseillers politiques des
dirigeants des pays membres du format
normandie ces contacts vise à contribuer
au rétablissement du cessez le feu et à
faire progresser le règlement du conflit
autour du dombass
selon l'elysée les deux présidents se
sont accordés sur la nécessité de
privilégier une solution diplomatique à
la crise actuelle est de tout faire pour
y parvenir il a été convenu toujours
selon l'elysée que le ministre français
des affaires étrangères juge jean-yves
le drian rencontrera son homologue russe
sergueï lavrov dans les prochains jours
quant à la partie russe on ne confirme
pas pour l'instant qu'une conversation
téléphonique entre les deux chefs de
diplomatie demain le 21 février le
président français s'est également
entretenu avec son homologue ukrainien
wladimir zelensky hier et ce dimanche
après sa conversation avec le président
russe selon l'elysée le président
craignant a confirmé son souhait de ne
pas réagir aux provocations et de
respecter le cessez le feu